gonna have a very big night and it's
going to be very exciting for us
[Music]
no matter who you vote for you have to
vote
and this is going to be a very important
election
hopefully the right thing will happen
I think they will I think they're great
candidates
I really think it's been a brilliant
campaign
[Applause]
so I think number one is going to be
grind it's going to be keeping your
taxes low we gave the biggest tax cut in
history we gained the biggest
regulations
you know the Democrats want to raise
that all up and we want to keep the
taxes well I think you have to close up
the border and you have to do it quickly
because you have visions of people
coming into our country and our country
is being destroyed so that'll happen
that'll absolutely happen but okay you
have to fight ground you have to fight
to keep our taxes low and you have to do
something about the border and it has to
be done
[Applause]
are you considering a run again you're
big enough since you're teasing I think
Tuesday will be a very exciting day for
a lot of people and I look forward to
seeing you with Marla
yeah
thank you all thank you thank you
everybody